and find it encouraging that you are  proposing an initiative for reducing air  pollution except in accepting the  urgency it seems clear to me also that  climate change is a problem we can no  longer be left to a future generation  when it comes to the day of our common  home we are living at a critical moment  of history we still have time to make  the change needed to bring about a  sustainable and in the development for  we know that things can change  such change demands on our but a serious  and response the recognition not only of  the kind of the world we may be leaving  to our children but also to the millions  of people living under a system which  has overlooked our common home has been  part of this growth of the excluded  which cries out to heaven and which  today powerfully strikes our homes our  cities our societies to use a telling  face of the Reverend Martin Luther King  we can say that we have defaulted on a  promissory note and now is the time to  hone reach